it's madden nfl 22 and the wait is over
this is dave klein reading for richard
wakeling
after criticism that last year's game
was light on new content particularly as
it relates to franchise mode developer
e.a tiburon has introduced a number of
sweeping changes this time around for
madden 22 with the crowd being the most
prominent right out of the gate
here's the australian-born punter [ __ ]
to get things going and off we go from
seattle the new game day atmosphere
feature brings crowds to life with new
animations and remastered fan recordings
that more accurately replicate what
you're likely to see and hear on any
given sunday it also extends beyond the
cosmetic side too as the ball will fly
further in denver's high altitude while
the wind will play havoc with your field
goal team in chicago on top of this the
intensity of the home fans will have an
impact on the way games can play out
this feature is called game day momentum
and it introduces a momentum meter to
the top of the screen that will shift
back and forth like a tug of war
depending on the performance of each
team if momentum is on your side you'll
gain access to various bonuses called m
factors that give your team an edge in
certain situations
this works in tandem with game day
atmosphere to ratchet up the
significance of home field advantage
especially when playing in front of
crowds known for their vociferousness
[Applause]
to throw is garoppolo
man open that's debo samuel
it looks and sounds a tad gamified on
the surface but game day momentum and
atmosphere are crucial additions that
capture the unique fandom of each team
and accurately reflect the wild swings
and momentum that can occur during the
course of a heated football game it
gives rivalries that big game feel and
intensifies those drives where the home
fans are fervently working against you
the impact of home field advantage in
the nfl is tangible and can often be the
difference between winning and losing
yet madden 22 marks the first time the
series has truly emulated such an
integral part of the sport
next gen stats also contribute to the
game they experience by snazzing up the
broadcast package replays will show how
many seconds it took a blister to
collide with the quarterback or count up
how many yards a receiver racked up
after the catch on a big play aside from
adding to the presentation however
next-gen stats have a much more
significant impact on gameplay in
comparison madden 22 utilizes the nfl's
next-gen stats data to drive his ai
behavior resulting in more dynamic games
against the cpu
quarterbacks will react differently from
each other when under pressure some are
more likely to attempt throws into tight
windows and ball carriers will differ
when it comes to attempting to evade
tackles or break through them you'll
also see superstar wide receivers use
signature cuts and releases off the line
to try and get open when the defense
presses while a suite of new animations
make everything feel more fluid and
responsive whether you're throwing the
ball downfield or bursting through a
hole at the line of scrimmage
tackling in particular looks more
natural and varied and is more
satisfying as a result
if they have any thoughts of coming in
here and getting this road victory
that's not the way to start it out on
the first play of the game in franchise
mode these improvements to ai help
diversify each week of the grueling nfl
season each team has its own personality
and play calling style so no one game is
similar to the last to counteract each
team's strengths and exploit their
weaknesses franchise has been overhauled
with new weekly strategies now next gen
stats will give you a breakdown of how
good a team is in a number of specific
areas on both sides of the ball from
executing outside runs and medium passes
to blitzing the quarterback and
defending short passes with this
information on hand you can choose a
game plan that gives you the best chance
to win against the steelers for instance
you might opt to counter their
aggressive blitz then in the next game
you might focus on containing the
quarterback in an attempt to stop the
cardinals kyler murray from scrambling
for yards on the ground while you spend
the week leading up to a game working on
strategy the halftime break gives you a
chance to alter the plan if things
aren't working or you want to adopt a
different approach because you're say up
big or trailing behind managing your
player's fatigue and injuries is another
part of the weekly strategy too you
might want to go all out and practice
before facing a rival team to boost your
players xp but you need to weigh up the
risks with the rewards in case one of
your key players ends up injured on the
eve of the contest one of the
franchise's other new features can at
least mitigate injuries to some extent
your head coach offensive coordinator
defensive coordinator and player
personnel all have their own rpg style
skill trees by meeting game day and
longer term goals you'll unlock staff
points that can be spent on improving
your staff in multiple areas such as
decreasing injury recovery time
improving your staff results in better
development of your players giving
franchise a rewarding loop as better
players means you're more likely to
complete goals to in turn improve your
coaches again each of these new and
revised systems gives madden 22 greater
strategic depth beyond simple roster
construction
if you're playing as a head coach
franchise also introduces story lines
over the course of each season to
reflect the ups and downs the team must
endure
these scenarios add faint narrative
elements to the game but mostly it's
another way to improve players by
setting them dynamic goals if a player
performs well during pre-season you
might talk to them about having a big
game to start the regular season this
will give you a game day goal to
continue their breakout earning more
staff points if you're successful
scouting on the other hand is unchanged
at the moment but developer tiburon
expects to launch a new scouting system
for free in september
ultimate team and the yard also return
but are mostly untouched from last year
the latter a unique 6-6 backyard
football experience as new fields
including hawaii and a new ranked mode
so you can test your skills against
other players progression in the yard is
also unified across face of the
franchise united we rise so all players
progress rewards and gear are shared
between the two modes face of the
franchise is also similar to last year
only now you're able to play as either a
quarterback running back wide receiver
or linebacker the story here is cliched
and stale with stilted cutscenes and a
lack of chemistry amongst the small cast
watching a young player go through
college before entering the draft is an
overused plot at this point even if
madden 22's version focuses on the
relationship between a player and his
agent as opposed to something like a
teammate rivalry there isn't enough here
to warrant playing face of the franchise
over the regular franchise mode the
addition of a new class based system
that defines your playstyle is a nice
touch giving you specific x-factor
abilities to work towards unlocking but
unless you like taking a created
character through an nfl season there
isn't enough depth nor incentive to
devote time to face of the franchise
it's not without its fair share of
glitches either the subtitles during
cutscenes often disappear music will
sometimes overpower dialogue and your
created character's face has a tendency
to completely change at random
madden 22 also has a habit of crashing
throughout all modes giving the
impression that it's not quite ready to
launch yet you can pick back up where
you left off after most of these crashes
but occasionally it will freeze at the
end of a game and wipe all of your
progress leaving a game in progress and
returning to it later will also reset
your game day goals even if you've
completed them and sometimes a win will
count as an awesome franchise these
technical issues put a damper on madden
22 particularly since it finally
addresses franchise with a number of
meaningful additions
when everything's working as intended
madden 22 marks a recent high point for
this series the gameplay doesn't move
the needle much mechanically but changes
to the ai make for a more interesting
and varied challenge while game day
atmosphere momentum brings every team's
fans to life to palpable effect with
franchise making the moments between
these games more engaging it's
relatively easy to sink hours into
building a team to challenge for the
super bowl it's just unfortunate that
this comes with the caveat that
technical problems might prove to be the
biggest obstacle standing in your way
he'll let this go deep for sutton
and this is dropped oh boy
a chance for a big play early but he
could not secure it nice play there to
force the incompletion